on se bouge nous sommes à alençon les
premiers les derniers c'est un film il
passera après ce qu'on va voir
maintenant ce qu'on va écouter qui est
formidable s'appelle vk ng maxime est
également thomas vous allez de
comprendre en quelques instants
c'est à la luciole demain soir à 21h
deux joueurs
coeur
thomas voici donc l'album devait cannes
j'ai sorti l'année dernière
là vous êtes en résidence à la luciole
d'alençon est ce que c'est pour
peaufiner cet album-là brun pour la
scène où est ce que c'est pour créer de
nouveaux morceaux qui commence maxime ou
thomas et ben les jv c'est pour faire un
petit peu tout ça on va peaufiner des
anciens morceaux créer des nouveaux
surtout fabriquer les lumières
car
non
alors votre musique commence toujours
défi difficile de définir une musique
elle est teintée des années 70's
nord-ouest cause de choses comme ça vous
êtes des amis d'enfance je jouerai le
rappeler oui on est des amis d'enfance
et c'est vrai que on flaire pop music
voilà un sermon très large comme il peut
être le dimajazz de mots pop music ça
englobe plein de styles différents non
c'est vrai quand on a des influences à
la fois comme marvin gaye ou plus proche
de nous et c'est des sound systems voilà
partis pour lancer ces deux choses très
différentes on fait des chansons
maxime et thomas sont issus du jazz
parfois dans le jazz thomas neill il ya
quand même un côté un peu on est entre
nous et le jazz ya pas mieux c'est on va
pas redescendre à faire de la variété ou
d'apam musique arrive aussi dans le jazz
ça arrive mais je crois que ça arrive
dans tout l'est dans tous les styles
musicaux et aussi des en choeur qui
supportent pas le jazz et des musiciens
classiques qui suspend paleron
sérieusement on fait dans chaque style
musical il ya toujours une chapelle en
des gens évidemment qui rebondit
uniquement ce style là et pas vous non
non mais nous on fait aussi partie
quelque part certainement d'une chapelle
ayant qui revendique d'anti chatel on
sent plus venez découvrir l'univers de
veka ng on pourrait dire vikings aussi
mais je veux bien les deux c'est une
influence us écrivais-je voilà ça
s'appelle avec angie c'est demain soir à
la luciole à partir de 21h donc ne
manquez pas ce groupe on pauvres ou des
vicas trélody à la fin voici ce qu'a dit
le premier et le dernier j'étais mort et
je suis revenu à la vie
là où ça bouge avec bouli lanners et sa
bande sur huit dire pour la sortie de
son film
quatrième film qui s'appelle les
premiers et les derniers on aurait pu
dire aussi les derniers et les premiers
s'étirer de saint-paul verser 20 les
volets seraient les premiers et les
derniers c'est pas de moi
moi j'avais envie de dire que c'est un
western dans la forme mais c'est une
forme de western contemporain est un peu
crépusculaire
il ya clairement des références au
western dans le film dans la forme parce
qu'il faut se faire plaisir aussi que
j'aime beaucoup les westerns
vous êtes mort il est quand même un don
pour trouver les endroits les nuls par
les nulle part mais ça me prend beaucoup
de temps
j'écris en fait en faisant des repérages
donc bonjour père pendant deux ans parce
que l'écriture prend du temps ça prend
deux ans donc mais j'alterne les deux
l'un nourrit l'autre il rien autres ça
parle de l'homme essentiellement c'est à
dire que ça parle d'eux s'il fallait
résumer la thématique sait ce qui nous
reste à vivre si même c'était la fin du
monde parce qu'il ya un sentiment de
faire du monde qui est habitée par les
personnages dans le film ce qui nous
reste à vivre comment vit le vip on voit
là est ce qu'on le vit dans le déni de
la vie où est-ce qu'on le vit pleinement
et en étant d'un humanisme absolue je
suis plus jeune que toi jenner plus
notamment l'après violence et j'ai l'air
pieux western ou conte philosophique on
peut dire ça aussi un peu des deux les
premiers et derniers de bouli lanners
sortie nationale mercredi 27 à là où ça
bouge on a adoré